[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT JENSON: I'm
on the Chrome team.
I've been at Google--
I joined in 2005.
I was there for many years.
I left.
I actually came
back two years ago
to specifically work on
this particular project.
I'm quite interested in it.
And it all came from something
I noticed a couple years ago,
which is the fact that we have
more and more smart devices
that we're all seeing around.
And each one of them
has their own smart app.
And that's, of course,
totally understandable.
That's how this kind of
thing has to work right now.
But if we believe in
Moore's law at all,
where are we going with this?
And what's going to
happen in six months?
happen in 12 months?
And are we really going to
have smart apps for absolutely
everything?
And this is especially true
in the public space, where
you want to use something
in a mall or an airport,
where you're not going to be
installing the vending machine
app as you walk past it.
So for those type of
lightweight situations,
how can we make this happen?
Because, to a certain extent,
the super power of the web
is the fact that it has
interaction on demand.
You can literally
go to any experience
on the planet with just a tap.
It's just a tap away.
And I think that's kind
of useful for the internet
of things and smart devices.
So how can we make that happen?
Because, over the
last, say, 30 years,
we've gotten very
excited by the DOM--
the Document Object
Model of the web.
And we've spent all of our
energy doing really cool things
inside of that box.
There's no question
that's really powerful,
but we've hardly done anything
at all for this little box
at the top, this URL bar.
We have to type something in.
I mean, if we want
to go anywhere, we've
got to kind of dub, dub,
dub, dub, you know, CNN.com.
And that's kind of silly.
We've taken the most amazing
rendering engine on the planet,
and we've slapped a damn DOS
prompt on top of it, which
just seems really weird.
It's like, really, why can't
the web on mobile start
to take advantage of the
sensors that have been there
for an awful long time.
So the Chrome team
basically feels that the web
needs a discovery service.
Why must you be on
your mobile phone,
and if you want to
go to a website,
you actually have to
type something in.
That's just right
out of the 1980s.
So that really seems
kind of strange.
So the idea would
be is, let's say
there's three things in the
environment-- a bus stop,
a parking meter, and
a vending machine--
and you wanted to actually
interact with one of them.
What would you have to do?
Well, if each one is
broadcasting a URL--
and we'd like to imagine
there's many technologies that
can do this, but let's,
just for the moment,
stick with Bluetooth
Low Energy--
and it was finding that beacon.
And you were to walk into
that space, what would happen?
Now, we could just
take the URLs and just
give you a list of them, but--
and URLs are really important
for transparency in
domains and so forth,
but it's not quite enough.
What you'd like to
be able to have is,
like, a title, and
a little snippet,
and maybe a little icon to
explain what you're picking.
And then, once you
actually got that,
you would then, of course,
just take you to the website.
It's really that lightweight.
The idea is to discover,
and show, and go
as quickly as you possibly can.
And how this would
work is, right now,
for the v1 version
that we're doing,
is it's just using
Bluetooth Low Energy, which
is broadcasting
in the advertising
packet of the beacon.
This is a standard part
of Bluetooth Low Energy.
It just broadcasts a URL
in the advertising packet
over, and over, and over again.
And then what would
happen, of course,
is that your phone would have
a simple scanner that would
say, "I know what that is.
I can show that to you."
And then give a little
list to the user.
It's really just that simple.
It's a very tiny
bit of technology
that we're trying to do here.
And that's essentially
all that The Physical Web
is, is this bridge between
physical and the web.
So, you walk up to
a parking meter,
it's broadcasting the URL.
You can then kind of
see it, and in you go.
But what people, I don't
think, appreciate sometimes
is how simple this idea is.
We're not really
asking for much.
We just want things to
have their own web pages.
But it's just a web page.
And so people are so used
to having a big portal
that millions of people
go to, as opposed
to a web page for every device.
It's kind of flipping the
whole problem on its head.
And the idea is that
you would literally
be able to walk up
and use anything--
whether it would be a
vending machine, a parking
meter, a movie poster.
It could even be a lost dog
collar, if you wanted it to be.
Every device has this
virtual note card
of just more information.
But the critical
thing is that we've so
imprinted upon existing
beacon solutions
that we assume that this
must beep in your pocket,
this must be some
kind of vibration.
And anybody who remembers
Bluetooth Classic
in the 1990s, that had
Bluetooth messaging,
realizes that that
was a really bad idea.
Because the spammers
got a hold of it
and ruined it for everybody.
We can't have this
thing vibrate,
because it's a universal system.
You'd walk into a mall, and
your phone would jump out
of your pocket, it
would be so, kind of,
on fire with notifications.
So this can only
work if the user
pulls her phone out and says,
show me the things around.
We have to respect the
user's attention, here,
and only do it when
they ask for it.
It's a big difference
from previous models.
So the idea is pretty
simple, in the sense
that you just have a device
that broadcasts a URL
and it takes you to the cloud.
That's really it.
But I always get two questions,
right away, right off the bat.
So I'll just save you
guys, because this is only
going to be 15 minutes, and I
want 15 minutes of questions.
The first question
I always get is,
well, isn't this just
a QR code, come on?
I'm like, well,
technically, yes.
It's a QR code.
I like to think of it as
a really awesome QR code.
It's a little bit different,
because the intention,
of course, of the
QR code, you have
to see one thing at a
time, and you actually
have to get close and do that.
Whereas here, you can see
a dozen-- multiple dozens--
of things at the same time.
Or, more importantly, instead
of being on top of the object,
it can literally
be 50 meters away.
So it's a whole
different usage case.
Also, QR codes are popular
in a couple countries,
but they tend to be on used
things-- like receipts,
and advertising in
magazines, or posters.
There's a very limited use
case for where they work.
You would not put a QR code
on a light bulb, or a toaster,
or a refrigerator.
It just doesn't make sense.
The other question
I get all the time
is, won't this generate spam?
If this is the web, and
anybody can take a URL,
and anybody can slap
it over anywhere,
it's going to be just chaos.
And I'm like, well,
it's kind of the web.
And the web is kind of chaotic.
But we have a way of
dealing with this.
We basically grab
all URLs around you,
and we don't show them directly
to the user for two reasons.
One is, we don't want to
contact each website directly.
The user could be fingerprinted.
That would be a leak of privacy.
So we have to protect the user.
And we put them all
through a proxy.
And the proxy, then, can then
contact on the user's behalf,
which protects them.
But it also allows us
to run a spam filter
on it and a phishing
filter and kind of get rid
of the low-hanging fruit.
Also, right now,
we are encouraging
only HTTPS domains,
which vastly gets rid
of a lot of the
low-hanging fruit, as well.
So it helps, effectively,
to kind of train
the chaos a little bit.
We are built on
top of Eddystone.
Eddystone is the
underlying beacon format
you've probably heard 75
times in the last two days.
And there's three classic
formats-- the UID,
the telemetry, and the URL.
We're using the URL packet.
And we just pack a URL inside.
We have a simple
compression scheme
to get rid of some of
the obvious things,
like HTTPS://www.
is one byte.
It's a form of just
simple encoding.
But that's what we're
built on top of.
We are the scanner on
top of Eddystone URL.
So what we're
trying to create is,
effectively, two
clouds-- a cloud
of devices that are
broadcasting URLs in a very
standard format--
so everybody is
broadcasting URLs
in the same way--
and then a whole
range of scanners.
Now, right now, there
are no scanners.
It's just us, and
we're building it.
But that's why we're
doing this open source.
I love coming back to
Google to the Chrome team,
because the Chrome
team is just filled
with Boy Scouts,
who just want to do
the right thing for the web.
And so the beacons
code is open source,
the scanner is open source,
the proxy is open source.
We want there to be lots
and lots of people scanning
and showing The Physical Web.
It's not our job
to be our product.
We're just kind of kick-starting
this new open web format.
So we will be the first one we
hope will get people excited.
But already there are two
or three other companies
making their own scanners.
And we're, like, super
excited about this happening.
So let me give you an example.
I've talked an awful lot.
Here's a couple examples of
products that you could build.
So what we're doing right now
is showing a Happy Meal toy.
And it is using The Physical
Web to get to the web page.
But, because there's a
new W3C standard that
uses JavaScript to
speak Bluetooth,
it allows you to actually
connect to the toy
and control it directly.
So here's how it happens.
We're using The
Physical Web to find it.
And there we see, right
there, Tuba the Turtle.
We click it.
Now The Physical Web is done.
We're now classic
web at this point.
It shows you the web page.
Now you can actually control
it by picking various things.
You make it happy,
or silly, or grumpy.
You kind of choose
its personality.
And the color changes.
And you can't tell, but
it's vibrating and changing.
Or you can change
the actual color.
And the whole idea
is that you're
kind of configuring
this for your child.
You put the phone away, and now
it's got its own personality.
You turn it upside down,
and it gets all grumpy
and it vibrates.
We had way too much
fun building this.
We actually had to stop, because
we weren't really building
The Physical Web anymore.
We were building a toy.
But it shows you how fun it is
to build this kind of stuff.
And this could be built
for a couple bucks.
It would be really
inexpensive to do.
And it's just
using a device that
has Bluetooth and a
couple-- a little [? gaps ?]
service to it-- no internet
connectivity of any kind.
Now this is probably our
most aggressive concept,
because it uses all
the latest cool stuff.
We've got a product sending
a Bluetooth beacon to me.
I'm going to the web, and
I'm getting a web page
with this new web Bluetooth
JavaScript library-- which
is, by the way, a W3C standard.
And then you can then talk
right back to the device.
What people like about it is
that there's no cloud here.
The device is just
talking directly to me.
I need the cloud to
get to the web page,
but that's just a one
time shot to get that.
Now, the flip side, the
completely different way
of thinking about this is to do
what we call Classic Web, which
is imagine, say, for
example, a bus stop that's
broadcasting a URL.
And I go to the cloud,
and I just get a web page.
That is not a smart bus stop.
It's a concrete pole,
full of concrete,
it just simply just gives
me some information.
Simple, it's
lightweight, and we feel
like this unlocks all sorts
of really interesting things
that you can do.
But this is what I mean by
having this virtual note card.
Whether it's a movie poster
or anything like that,
it can be really interesting.
But what we also discovered
was kind of almost a surprise--
that there's so much
going on in the web,
it's getting so much better.
It's making us look awesome,
and we don't deserve it at all.
There's just a lot of
really cool web technologies
that are coming on top of it.
So, for example, if you've
heard of Service Worker that's
coming-- also
another standard-- it
allows you to sign up for
push notifications, which
the user opts in to being able
to be beeped at a later time.
So in this particular
case, I'll show you
this restaurant buzzer.
I'll flip over here.
So you pull down the Manager
and you see Bob's Deli.
Again, Physical Web done.
That was, like, four seconds.
We're now on a web page
that says, "Hey, there's
eight people in front of you.
Take a number."
You can now sign up for
a push notification.
You turn off the phone.
You put it in your pocket.
Then what happens is, it's
your turn in line at the deli.
It sends you a push
notification, your phone beeps,
"Bob's Deli," and you go.
Now, in this case, it did
vibrate in your pocket,
but you opted in.
You asked for it.
It's a big difference.
And, again, The Physical Web is
identical for both the turtle
and the restaurant.
It's just the web
made it more awesome
and did it on top of it.
And the last one I want to talk
about is Cloud Passthrough.
And this is maybe more of
a developer difference.
It's not really the same.
I mean, from the user
experience point of view,
you're walking up to a
device and you're using it.
But it's fun to explore
the plumbing differences.
In this case, the smart
parking meter sends you a URL.
You go to the cloud, and
then the cloud actually
talks directly to that device.
It's just using web sockets.
It's just pushing
[? it then ?] to the device.
So here's how this would work.
Here's a parking meter we made.
I'm pulling down the
Notification Manager.
I just see the fact that
it's Pay at Parking right
in front of me, and I click it.
Again, Physical Web is done.
Now at this particular
point, the parking meter
is on the internet.
It has its own connectivity,
separate from the phone.
I go up, up, and
the number goes up.
I hit Pay, that authorizes it,
and it goes, and we're done.
Whenever I show this
in San Francisco,
people just cry a little bit.
Because, you know, we have
that parking system here,
and nobody can figure
out how to use it.
Now, I will admit I
cheated a little bit here.
Because I had already
used it once before,
so I knew whatever my
payment system was.
And people always ask, well,
are you using Google Pay?
I don't care.
It's the web.
Pick your payment system.
It's just simply whatever web
system that you want to have.
But, once you had that
in place, it literally
would be that many
clicks, and you'd be done.
So I want to stress one
critical point here,
though, that what we're talking
about with The Physical Web
is the ability for you to
find the URL on the phone
and then take you to a web page.
That's our job.
It's effectively just a really
awesome QR code side of things.
Everything else that
you saw was the web.
I've gotten asked many times,
"Scott, what's your SDK?"
And I'm like kind of going,
"Well, I don't have one."
Because, I mean, we don't.
We just get you to a web page.
It's up to you to go from there.
We don't have an SDK.
It's just simply, you just
take a beacon, and slap it up,
and you're done.
So the intention
is that-- and a lot
of times when I show people
the Cloud Passthrough,
they're like,
"Yeah, but come on.
Are you really going
to have a device that's
connected to the internet?"
But like, you have heard of
The Internet of Things, right?
I mean, you can get,
effectively, GSM
modems now from a company called
Particle that's, like, $39.
And it has GSM connectivity
and it gets 10,000 messages
a month.
I mean, it's not a
big deal now to make
a device that's connected to
the internet that gets messages.
So, what I think is
going to be very likely,
over the next year or
two, is that devices
will have their connectivity.
I'll have my connectivity.
And we'll be in a public space.
There's no way that we're
on the same network.
The idea that we're
going to the same subnet
is totally appropriate
for enterprise and home.
I'm not saying it isn't.
But in public spaces,
you're not going
to be connecting to its
Wi-Fi so you can talk to it.
That doesn't make any sense.
You just simply want to a URL
to say, just meet me over here.
Just, I'll just meet you
over there, and that's fine.
So it's really meant
to be lightweight
way to kind of rendezvous
kind of in the cloud.
We also found out that,
as we are playing,
is, the first thing I built--
I don't know if you guys saw
this-- but the first thing I did
was I built a vending machine.
I bought it on Craigslist.
I carried it in the office.
I ripped the guts out, put in a
Raspberry Pi, hooked it all up.
And everybody loved it.
It's fun to have this kind
of vending machine work.
But it was quite
clear that we were
thinking kind of like a
classic "control stuff" model.
We actually got much smaller.
It was like this idea
of bus stops I told you,
or movie posters.
But these are still
corporate ideas.
The more we played
with it, the more
we realized it unlocks all sorts
of really interesting personal,
consumer use cases.
So, imagine, for
example, that you're
giving-- we're actually
writing an extension right
now for Chrome OS.
So when you're
presenting Google Slides,
you're just presenting the URL
to everyone else in the room,
so they can also
see your slides.
It's a one-time thing that
happens for 30 minutes,
and then it's just done.
Or the fact that you could
put this on a dog collar.
And, normally, it would
just simply be a dog collar,
"I'm Sparky.
Hi."
You know?
But your dog were to
be lost, you'd call,
and the web page would change
and say, "I was lost at 7:15,
and call this number."
It could be the Humane
Society, or whatever,
and it would be like a system
to help you find your dog.
It's just a web page to
help you find your dog.
Or even a for sale sign.
You would take a for sale sign
from the back of your car,
but it could also link to
photos of the car, records,
service records, and so forth.
It just adds a richness
and a depth to things.
So we feel this unlocks
an awful lot, especially
because these beacons are
getting so inexpensive.
So the web is famous for
this long tail of content.
You know, like, the
bottom 99% of the web
is bigger than the
1% type of thing.
Because there's just so
many cool little things.
Every example I showed you
today from vending machines,
to bus stops, to luggage, or
toasters, is kind of-- meh,
it's OK.
But taken together,
it forms what
we're kind of calling the
Long Tail of Interaction.
It's the fact that
you could literally
interact with almost anything
in a very lightweight way.
And I want to stress that
it doesn't require the IoT.
People often think that The
Physical Web is the IoT.
And it's like, well, actually
we're just the UX gateway.
We get you to that.
Because, for example, I
can talk to a toaster.
I mean, so many people take
toasters-- or any device--
and they unpack it from the box.
And it's got URLs and
QR codes all over it.
And you unpack it, and
you throw the box away.
And some poor marketer
loses his wings, right?
Because this opportunity
has been lost, right?
Well, imagine that URL could
now live inside the toaster.
And you could-- now if you're
just going to push insurance
on them, that's ridiculous.
But if you were to have,
how to clean the crumb
tray, and the recipe of the
week, and how to recycle it,
you could actually add
value to this toaster.
It would be quite interesting.
And it's still just
a dumb toaster.
There's no IoT
involved whatsoever.
It's just engagement
with the user.
So we feel like
there's an awful lot
of value to The Physical
Web outside of the IoT.
So we announced about, what,
15 months ago on GitHub.
We're one of Google's most
popular GitHub reposts.
We feel very strongly
about being open source.
As I said before, the beacon,
the scanner, the server--
it's all open source.
And it's quite active.
People are asking
lots of questions.
It's also quite
exciting, the fact
that Opera has already announced
that they've got a scanner.
I bumped into somebody today.
Blink's, they're working
on their own scanner.
This makes us very
excited, because this
has to be a part of the web.
It can't succeed if it's
exclusively a Google product.
It only will succeed if we, as
a community, want it to succeed,
which is why I come out and
talk about this so much.
It's just part of
the generic open web
that anybody can be a part of.
So we announced a Chrome Dev
Summit, about last month,
that we are shipping Physical
Web in Chrome, but just to kind
of kick start the market.
If you happen to have
Chrome on your IOS machine,
right now, you have
The Physical Web.
And you just didn't know it.
All you have to do is
open up the Today View,
and turn on the Chrome
widget, and you'll
see the beacons that we're
broadcasting around you, right
now.
I'm seeing people
diving, right now.
It's kind of cool.
We are in Chrome for
Android in the Dev
build-- which means you've
got to go turn on a flag,
and reboot the machine.
It's a little bit
more for developers.
We are working very
quickly to kind of get it
into a public release,
which should be coming out
this quarter.
And we're very excited
for that coming.
That should really, we think,
unlock an awful lot more.
We have a much
better on onboarding
experience with
Android, as well.
Because what we're
going to be able to do
is vibrate when you're
nearby a beacon, one time.
And say, "Oh, can I turn
on The Physical Web?
There's something nearby."
And the user can say, no.
But if they say,
yes, we will then
opt them into The
Physical Web, and that'll
get them up and running.
We think that's going to be
a much better experience.
And we hope by getting the
hundreds of millions of Android
users working
this, this is going
to really help quite a bit.
So this is taking off right
now, and we're hoping that,
say-- like I said,
by the beginning
of second quarter-- it will
be a lot more activity for you
guys to play with.
So I tried very hard to
keep this to 15 minutes.
I've got 15 minutes more to go.
This usually engenders
tons of questions,
so I wanted to wrap up, say
thank you for your time,
and take some questions.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So how
does Chrome prevent
the agents from the
first order from snipping
the packets from--
SCOTT JENSON: What?
AUDIENCE: --well, the beacons
or the [INAUDIBLE], whatever,
and phish your Chrome and
find a [? BB8 ?] and--
SCOTT JENSON: Well, as
I mentioned before, we
take many, many steps, right?
So we make sure, for
example, that we're only
using the advertising packet,
not the scan response packet.
That protects you from
malicious beacons.
Then we make sure that
we use a proxy service
to make sure it
contacts the website.
That prevents you from
being fingerprinted.
We then use a filter
service to make sure
that all malicious websites,
that we can detect,
are removed.
And then we open it
up inside the browser,
which has its own sandbox.
So we take multiple
steps along the way.
And HTTPS, by the
way, prevents any "man
in the middle" attacks.
AUDIENCE: What about
the beacon communicating
to your smart phone?
SCOTT JENSON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you verify that
this is authentic, that this--
SCOTT JENSON: We don't.
It's just a URL.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but could I
phish the URL [INAUDIBLE]?
SCOTT JENSON: Well, we would--
our proxy service would then
remove that phishing
URL from your list,
assuming we can detect it.
I mean, it's-- by the way, I
don't want to guarantee it.
It's always-- it's always
an acceleration, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SCOTT JENSON: Anybody who
says 100% guarantee is clearly
selling you something, right?
So you can't do that.
AUDIENCE: Have any other
beacon platforms picking it up?
SCOTT JENSON:
Beacon-- well, we're
based on top of Eddystone.
And so, there's, what,
18 to 25-- depending
on who you count--
beacons manufacturers
that are doing this.
And they're all--
the feedback we've
been getting is really strong.
Because they've tried the kind
of the classic approach before,
and they find it's just really
hard to get small company
apps to be installed.
And so once anybody can
kind of go into a store
and get an experience
without selling an app,
they're, like, pretty
excited by that.
So, like anything,
I think it's going
to be a chicken or the egg.
So we're talking to a lot
of advanced ad agencies,
experimental places,
As soon as we--
I think, once we ship on
Chrome to 800 million phones,
I think a lot more
people will get started.
But let's be clear.
It's going take a little while
for the ecosystem to grow.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I got super
excited about this.
And I noticed, in our
little kits that we got,
it came with a Bluetooth beacon.
SCOTT JENSON: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Can I add
my own URL to that?
SCOTT JENSON: That is
a Bluvision beacon.
You need to use the
BEEKS app-- B-E-E-K-S.
And then when you
install that application,
it will allow you to set it.
Each beacon manufacturer,
at this point,
has its own
application to set it.
And we are actually
working on trying to make
that a more unified experience.
We hope to tell you more
about that in next quarter.
Because, obviously,
being able to set them
in a more uniform way would
be a very useful thing to do.
We've heard loud and
clear from people,
we need to improve that.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So could I suggest
that [INAUDIBLE] for beacons
like this have a default initial
URL with a link to the page
to [? bootstrap up ?]?
SCOTT JENSON: Well, if
you open up Physical Web,
you'll see it right now.
AUDIENCE: Good.
SCOTT JENSON: I
mean, right now, I
think the beacons
that you'll see
will be to the agenda
to this, and then one
to The Physical Web, and
there is one, I think,
to the front page.
So you should be able to see at
least three beacons, right now.
And I always carry one
in my pocket to my blog,
just because I'm a selfless,
shameless self-promoter.
And, by the way, we do
not recommend-- I mean,
the huge power of
The Physical Web,
right now, is primarily in
ephemeral public interaction.
A number of people
have thought, this
is a great idea to put on badges
and for people to carry around.
Well, now you're basically
advertising yourself
and walking around with a
very uniform fingerprint that
can be tracked.
So if you want to do something
that's very personal,
attached to people,
then you'd probably
want to go to the ephemeral
ID standard-- a very
different thing, a new
packet for Eddystone.
This primarily should be
attached to public things
for ephemeral lightweight
information that's
safe and public and open.
That just takes a lot
of the risk out of it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about
powering beacons?
Are you just limited to public
things that have power already?
SCOTT JENSON: So the question
is about powering beacons.
Beacons are changing
so radically.
The beacons I was
using a year ago
were half as efficient as
the ones I'm using right now.
So we've got a beacon right
now that's about this big,
with a [? CR24-75 ?] in it, and
it's lasted for three years.
And once you get past
two years, people
don't seem to care anymore.
And yet, these are basically
the, what, 2.4 volt?
There's already
been an announcement
of 1 volt chips, which will
last almost three times longer.
So we really do expect that
the battery issue is almost
going to go away within,
probably, 18 months.
I was just at CES.
There's a company
called [? Biko ?]
that basically has
a small device that
clips to fluorescent lights.
And they have a PV cell
inside, and that gives it
more than enough power.
So you clip it, and as
long as the light's on,
it runs forever.
So there's quickly
changing, this idea.
Keep in mind, by the way,
that the Bluetooth standard is
changing from 4.2 to 5,
which will become more
prevalent probably this fall.
So in a year and a
half to two years,
most people are going
to probably want
to change out the beacons
to the new standard, anyway.
So I think, by the
time we get to 5,
it's easy to imagine these
beacons lasting, if not five
years, indefinitely.
AUDIENCE: More power efficiency.
SCOTT JENSON: Significantly
more power efficiency, yeah.
We've definitely noticed that
it's changed an awful lot.
That, initially, a
lot of these SOCs
would take a tremendous
amount of power to power up,
and then the broadcasting would
be a much smaller part of it.
But now, what we're seeing
is they're so efficient, they
power up quickly and lightly,
and most of the power
is the actual transmission,
which is a good sign.
It means they're getting
much more efficient.
AUDIENCE: How about the range?
SCOTT JENSON: The range
is really up to you,
as far as how much
power you want
to pump into it in the antenna.
If you're willing to
plug it into a wall
and put a big
antenna, this sucker
could go 100 yards, 100 meters.
But most of these
systems are going to be,
like, say, 30 to 40 feet,
if you wanted to have
it last for a long time.
By the way, we do
simple little things,
which is like, in
this particular case,
we've blanketed this place
with about four beacons,
all broadcasting the same URL.
When you pull out
our scanner, we
may see three of those four
URLs, be we'll de-dupe them
and only show you
the one, right?
And that makes it
really easy for you
to just kind of wantonly scatter
them around, just to make sure
you get coverage,
but you'll just
see the one URL in the scanner.
Little things like
that are nice.
OK.
We're all set?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
SCOTT JENSON: OK.
That's the time.
And I'll be outside if
you have any questions.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]